if you just take tony as a case study
for a moment and what is it that faith
dozen these circumstances we analyze it
as opposed to just accept what he's done
and actually simple is a very good
example of this in fact geez from a
different religion the Prophet Muhammad
is a very good example of this the first
thing is you've got to be prepared to
believe that something that's wrong can
be changed into something that's right
you know a lot of people look at the
world they don't dispute there's
terrible things but I just say yeah but
actually what faith does is it gives you
an in a sense that things can be changed
then it have to be like that they can be
changed there's a sense of possibility
that comes with it the second thing I
think that comes with it is a
willingness to think differently and a
new and to challenge conventional wisdom
I mean I think what's interesting about
all the all the great prophets and let's
take it in the broader sense certainly
with the Abrahamic faiths but all the
great prophets of one thing in common
which is absolutely fascinating the
sense that now there's a there's a kind
of doctrine about them and that is they
were all challenging conventional
thinking you know Susan Paul absolutely
dramatically obviously but not just in
relation to Judaism and Christianity but
actually in relation to the practices of
Judaism some of which were kept that
some of which were altered there's some
Peter and Cornelius likewise so there's
that as well but again you could go
across the religious movements and you
look at any of the great teachers we
look at any of the great teachers within
for example Hindu religion they are all
people who are challenging the
conventional wisdom
and I think the third thing is that it
gets you is a determination to keep
going in the face of adversity and and
to recognize that there is something
more important than the transient good
opinion of any particular time and that
is what I think faith faith can only
mean something if at a certain vital
moment for all your weaknesses are and
limitations you are prepared to
surrender itself you know that's why
that's where isn't that means I mean
surrendered to God right so it's it's a
it's a fact that is that is a concept
that i think is dramatically important
in faith and so what they seem to do
something that would be very a that is
thinking he can actually change
something when most people have said
well how are you going to get them to
change that be he does it in
circumstances where he's prepared to do
something radically different and
challenged conventional wisdom and see
you keeps at it now I think those are
those are really important aspects and
they're in the way that faith can
interact with the way that you you do
things and that's and that's what you
notice and it's what you notice i mean i
am a you know many ways as a practicing
politician you know when you're in
government you're taking decisions the
whole tie right let's be honest about it
some of these decisions you're taking on
a very practical transactional basis
right I'm we go this way rather than
that way let's suss it out we got these
problems that you know that is the
business of politics and it's there but
there are always crucial moment in which
actually it's not a transactional issue
it can be either a transformational
issue or in certainly an issue of great
principle and it's at that point that
you've you work out within yourself
whether you're prepared to surrender
what might be actually a short term
self-interest to something bigger so
when Tony decides you know there may
describers in that case and finish him
off but nonetheless decides to do it now
the really difficult thing is if they
had finished your won't he be there but
actually the fact is you would still be
doing the same thing now that's that's
what it gives you and that's the
difference I think